hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
february 1st 2021 you made it through
the first month
of 2021 congratulations to you
you're so brave you're a warrior
you know january is one of the hardest
months to get through in the northern
hemisphere
it's the middle of winter there's not
28 days there's not 29 leap years
days it's not 30 there's a full
31 days
sorry i'm just trying to be woke and
make sure that i take the time
to thank everyone um i made the mistake
of looking at some twitter comments
i'm on my feed jesus christ
this one [ __ ] jerk off oh you know i
wish you podcast this subject
isn't funny so i shut it off in the
first four minutes
and i'm struggling to find there's no
struggle
there's no struggle buddy you listened
to it you didn't like it
you shut it off it's over
jesus christ everybody's trying to have
their [ __ ]
you know oprah at some point in oprah
interview you start crying
you know everybody tries to have that
now i listen to a podcast
and i'm struggling
you're struggling that's what you're
struggling with
everything that's going on right now
we're going into our third [ __ ]
decade of this war that didn't really
have a purpose and
[ __ ] we don't know when we're getting
out it's bankrupted they're not [ __ ] all
that
i listen to a podcast today and i am
struggling
after shutting it off still struggling
still struggling well good luck with
your struggle sir or ma'am
whoever the [ __ ] you are i hope uh
somehow you can
pick up the pieces and and find a way to
carry on because
i can't imagine what that must be like
to listen to a podcast done by someone
you don't know and have them have the
audacity
to talk about something that you don't
find funny
um anyway clown ahead here i got more
sad news i cannot believe this another
writer passed away
on episode family uh the great mark
wilmore
um i can't believe i'm saying this i'm
still stunned over david richardson
um you know
mark and david were just the two old
school guys
in the room that i'd love to vibe off of
mark is the re he look first of all he
wrote on a living color
he he was a cast member and then living
color he wrote on the simpsons he wrote
on the pjs with daddy murphy
and we were lucky enough mike price
brought him in to
uh efforts for family and
what i loved about that guy was
he could talk anything he wanted to talk
about
like he had this wealth of knowledge
he was a huge sports fan and likes
sports for all the right reasons
and and could remember
all of this stuff that i had no idea
about because he was um
he was like 57 gonna be 58 i'm 52 gonna
be 53 yes he had like four years on me
and those are a big four years for me
because
of that part of um sports history that
you know is so fascinating to me the end
of the afl
beginning of the nfl free agency you
know
was it kurt flood or something like that
he knew all of that stuff
he knew all of that stuff and then he
knew everything
about the rat pack and he had seen sammy
davis jr
live in vegas sinatra dean he had seen
all of them
he had all of these showbiz stories um
i mean his stories about stand-up
there was just really nowhere that you
could go as far as just my interests
you know sports cars entertainment
you know his social commentary all of
that mark is the reason
that um for everybody that loved that um
you know r is for rosie episode he was
the force behind that
the smoky greenwood character all those
guys in casper's bar
all of that so much of that was him
and then the tommy tahoe stuff who was
sort of our poor man's
you know sort of crooner
with his knowledge of seeing count basie
and seeing sinatra with basie and all
that stuff that he's he just added so
much to the room and he was such a
sweetheart of a guy
and i remember one day he was on the
phone
he had a tesla and it wasn't working
and uh just listening to him tearing
them a new [ __ ]
i remember we were all in the writers
room
sitting at the table just laughing our
ass off and also kind of like nervous
because we had never seen mark that
upset
and mark was one of these guys that when
he yelled he didn't get
louder his voice just went up and i just
remember at one point he's like
he just he's unfolding just going i
don't give a
[ __ ] he's like you [ __ ] are trying
to go to mars and you can't get me into
work from [ __ ]
san bernardino or something like that
and it was one of those deals where like
even when he was mad he was like
spitting out punchlines
so he was like killing with us we were
like
like where his office was that season
where the writer's room he's like right
next door to it
and um
i don't know i'm gonna miss him that
just sucks it sucks
it just sucks just him coming in
shuffling in and
he just always had all of these stories
him and richardson man i mean i
i talk about like an end of a [ __ ]
error
um yeah i don't know what to say i'm
absolutely just
stunned so sorry to keep bringing up
this is just people dying in my life
[ __ ] left and right
um anyway
anyway but i hope that guy listened to
the joke and didn't like it is doing all
right with this struggle
uh i mean i don't get people like that
it's like peanut butter and jelly
sandwich my mom
choked on a peanut butter jelly sandwich
when i was fine
how would i know that how would i know
that
[ __ ] you want me to sit up here with
sock puppets i'm not trying to [ __ ]
hurt anybody i'm just [ __ ] around
here
jesus [ __ ] christ anyways plowing
ahead so rest in peace
to uh the great mark wilmore thank you
so much for your friendship and
everything that you did on epis for
family and i can't believe that you're
gone
another thing he knew where all the
steakhouses were he told me about this
one
that's you know just east of hollywood
that's an old train car or whatever he's
like yeah you got to go down there
go down at this time there's a career
waiters you pay a little bit more money
like new all of those [ __ ] places
um all these places to eat and just
i don't know whatever i i'm
i'm sick of this [ __ ]
i'm sick of it anyway let's just let's
get on to something lighter here let's
talk uh let's talk sports
oh bo freckles lost some money
all freckles lost some money uh this
weekend
uh i bet on the bruins versus the caps
we went down three zip and uh
you know bruins facing zidane ochara for
the first time since he played with
ottawa all those years ago
and uh it was great to see him he still
looks as great as he ever was
um bruins got a lot of [ __ ] for letting
for not resigning him i don't understand
why it was like
we [ __ ] signed the guy like nine
million times he played with us for 15
years
he keeps doing those one-year contracts
at some point we got to move on
he has to move on he went to a great
club what's what's the [ __ ] problem
our defense is great cap's defense look
great or whatever
um so anyway i watched the game and i
just said [ __ ] you know
some guards and root beer floats steak
dinners
i just do it that way man um so i lost a
steak dinner on the celtics versus the
lakers
which was a great great game
i really enjoyed that um i've been
watching a lot of nba i really
i watched the great uh new orleans
pelicans versus the uh milwaukee bucks
pelicans were up by 30 points and the
bucks never quit it just [ __ ] came
came back got it within like three four
points before the pelicans
put it out of reach in the end just a
great game and that's a fun team to
watch by the way the pelicans are
and i was happy for that lonzo ball kid
because he's really coming on he's
hitting his threes and all that type of
[ __ ] i mean i know his dad
you know did what he had to do to get
him there but i mean it's just you know
it's got to be a lot for a kid to have a
dad like that
it's like all right dad shut up jesus
christ um so anyway
um it was great to see that and um
and see zion healthy i enjoyed watching
him and he kind of looks like uh
i don't know what he's either a giant
charles barkley or a mini shack he's
sort of like
in the middle of the two just completely
unique uh
just his body type in the size that he
is um it was fun man
it was really fun to watch that but it
was not fun to watch the celtics lose to
the lakers but
it was a great battle came right down to
the last possession
fortunately can be shot rattled in and
out what the [ __ ] you gonna do but i
know
considering the lakers the defending
champs i was happy we played
competitively against them i mean i know
it's different if it's a seven game
series
we shall see but i i at this point like
i don't know i watch
hoop i enjoy nba hoop but at this point
i've resigned myself to the fact that
every good player essentially
at some point it has a 80 chance of
being a laker
i'm just like all right the game has
moved on
from the way it used to be all right
bruins lose to the capitals in ot well
we were down
uh three to nothing and frederick tried
to pick a fight with wilson and wilson's
smart enough like dude we got all the
momentum we're up three games and i'm
not [ __ ] fighting you
who are you and frederick kept chirping
at him
so uh look out for that in game two i
was thinking you know once we made it
three to two
that maybe there was a chance or if the
caps went up four to nothing in the
third period
that wilson would drop him with
frederick so look for that
uh tonight uh monday night look for that
frederick versus wilson we'll see what
we'll see what happens see what the kids
got
wilson's a tough customer and he scores
goals um
i'm one of the few people that is not a
capitals fan but loves wilson
i know a lot of people hate that guy i
don't know i like him um
so anyway i i still haven't quite lost
that bet i got it
i was betting with josh adam myers he's
a big caps fan so we're playing
back-to-back games so
i lost the first one we shall see what
happened
but i did lose a nice [ __ ] sweet
steak dinner
on the celtics lakers uh what the [ __ ]
you gonna do
you know um anyway i'm loving the bruins
fourth line though
coralie and wagner and the other day uh
andres bjork was playing on him and he
had like the best game of his career
against the uh i think it was the
penguins that second game
um i don't know bruins look
really really solid look really solid
and we're still
getting healthy which is a great thing
you know it was uh what's his face
pasta just came back for the first time
we'll see what happens
you know we shall we shall meet again
with those capitals actually tonight
we're going to meet him again but i'm
saying down the road i want to see what
we look like down the road
because the caps are uh i guess they're
they're the
best in our northeast division whatever
you call it and how about [ __ ]
ovechkin
with that [ __ ] laser to win it in
overtime wasn't tipped
nobody in the way he just [ __ ]
blasted it right by tuka can't get mad
at that well you know you can always get
that's why i don't
i don't [ __ ] i don't bet money on
games because then if i lose i don't
give a [ __ ]
you know i bet a couple cigars and some
root beer floats yeah whatever i'm still
having a good time i better steak dinner
i mean i'm gonna get one too but you
know
it's gonna cost me a little more
um and i just got the uh what i thought
was the last of my plumbing problems but
they've discovered something else while
they were fixing it
so uh you know i don't know
what are you gonna do it's
it is what it is i think the sewage pipe
is the last thing i have to deal with
and uh the guy took a peek underneath
the crawl space and he is convinced that
it is the original
[ __ ] you know 90 100 year old [ __ ]
sewage pipe so you know that's what i'm
dealing with
that's what i'm dealing with oh by the
way you know i finally got caught up on
that whole game stock
scandal um i don't understand what the
scandal is it's just kind of funny that
the
the people who usually get [ __ ] were
the ones doing the [ __ ]
and then the rich guys shut the game
down
that's what [ __ ] blows my mind and
there's just no
[ __ ] i mean how many times do they
have to show that this country is run
by [ __ ] a handful of [ __ ] super
rich people
how many [ __ ] times it's unfucking
believable i think people just
don't want to [ __ ] hear it they just
don't want to hear it
so this is what happened i learned
basically for the 9 millionth time what
shorting a stock is
i had to look it up i had to call vinnie
brand from the stress factory i had to
have him explain it and then i had to
watch some videos so i think this is
basically what shorting a stock
is all right oh billy's over his [ __ ]
pay grade on this one
basically for whatever reason if you
have stock if you bought stock in
something for some reason
i can [ __ ] borrow it and then go sell
it to somebody else
all right like i can say like hey you
know you got that stock there in uh
the women's defibrillator there right
whatever the [ __ ] that would be
um well we found that the woman's heart
is a little different than a male's
heart
and over the last 20 years um anyways
so you got stalking women's
defibrillation right
it's going to be very laymen terms here
all right
so let's say the stock is worth 10 bucks
i go i want to borrow that
okay so that i'm allowed to borrow it
and then i can also
go sell it the only thing is is
however long you're letting me borrow it
for i have to give it back to you
you know and at which point you'll give
me my 10 bucks back right
women's defibrillation is is trading at
ten bucks of whack
oh god this is i've never sounded dumber
so i borrow it from you at ten bucks
then i put it into the market if i'm
going to short the stock i'm betting
that the stock is going to go down
because now i don't have it i just sold
it to somebody else
right so they buy it at 10 so right now
it broke even so what i'm hoping it is
is the bottom is going to fall out of it
so then i can buy it back for like eight
bucks
and then when i take it and give it back
to the guy i borrowed it from he's
giving me my 10 bucks back and i just
made two bucks
now obviously you you multiply that time
numerous shares then you can actually
make some decent money
so essentially what happened
um obviously the more money you have
two things it seems you have a higher
chance of making a [ __ ] load of money
shorting stocks and then
also because you can buy you can borrow
so many
and then dump them into the market you
can create this
artificial look that this stock is
plummeting
so then everybody else starts dumping
their stocks
right which drives it down and then what
you do is you right where you see it
starts to settle at the bottom
you go back in and buy whatever the 10
000 shares
that you paid 100 grand for you then buy
them back
all of them back for like 25 grand and
then you give it back to the guy and you
just made 75 grand well
this was a game for [ __ ] rich people
so evidently
a group of kids or something on reddit
somehow figured out that there was these
big hedge funds with gamestop
which is a strip mall slash mall store
that sells video games was gonna go out
of business
so they decided that they were gonna
short the stock now i don't get how this
works like who the [ __ ] doesn't know
that they're going out of business
they sell video games they're a a brick
and mortar store in a [ __ ] strip mall
or
a mall you would think that yeah your
days are numbered but whatever so they
[ __ ] buy
a bunch of this stuff they borrow a
bunch of this stock to flood the market
to cause it to go down and then they're
going to short it and they're going to
buy it back and then give it back to
people they're basically going to profit
off the fact that this thing's
is [ __ ] in the bed so evidently these
kids on reddit what they did was when
they float when these rich guys flooded
the market with it
was they bought it and they bought up
every bit of it that they could
and then because it was even though it
was being dumped the fact that they were
buying it gave it value and then the
price of it went through the [ __ ]
roof
it went from eight dollars i heard up to
three hundred dollars a share
so now these rich fuckos
who probably let's say you know eight
bucks a share
bought a hundred thousand of them
right so their buy-in was 800 grand
to get those 100 shares back
they now had to spend 30 million dollars
and a couple and that's what i guess
basically what happened in a couple
billion dollars was lost
and like super rich people's portfolios
were going to be completely
wiped out the way super rich people
wipe out the savings of of regular
people and veterans all the [ __ ] time
during the stock market right
they are so [ __ ] rich they said no
uh-uh
stop and they just shut it down they
just stopped tomorrow they hit freeze
and said you can't [ __ ] do that
i saw some guy now listen i need to read
up way more on this this is essentially
what happened
and then this [ __ ] guy goes this was
basically an attack on rich
i people it i loved the story but i
gotta tell you
i also understand the concern about it
okay because now what you have is that
was essentially the metoo movement of
the stock market
where they were they essentially i don't
know
can't even say exposed people knew that
that was happening but they basically
were rising up against
these people that had this control and
who had done all this toxic horrible
stuff to other people all right
if you believe that you might say well
you know it's capitalism it's how [ __ ]
it works it's not capitalism it's an
oligarch right
all the money's in the hands of a few
[ __ ] people come on stop but what i
will say about this country is
some [ __ ] like me can't go out and
tell some jokes and make some nice
nice money that he then loses on a
bruins and celtics game
to the tune of you know cigars root beer
floats and steaks
um anyway um
what's crazy now is that's the first
time
regular people have all gotten together
on would you consider reddit a social
media site i don't know what it is
i don't understand what reddit is reddit
is like people who like to type
it's like a giant chat room right it's a
i don't know um people with strong
thumbs go on [ __ ] reddit they got a
lot to say out there
so this now has opened the door that
just like
what's to stop some other group of
people from doing this so what i i what
i do
love about it is now all these [ __ ]
rich people have to look over there they
get to feel
what the [ __ ] they've made everybody
else feel
um over the last century in the goddamn
stock market so
i do like that but then also you know
just listening to the average [ __ ]
person when you walk down the goddamn
street
you know especially during the whole
pandemic here
you really understand why you need a
small group of people
running [ __ ] because
there's so many mouth-breathing morons
out there so you combine that
with the [ __ ] stock market this is
gonna be uh this could get crazy so
we'll see what happens
but it's so blatantly [ __ ] obvious
that the market is like not even
controlled by the governing body that's
supposed to be controlled
it's just it's the same thing as the
president the president
is is is i've always said this it's like
when your flight is delayed you know
when you [ __ ] yell at the person
behind the ticket counter
that's what the president is you never
get to the owner of the airline
so i feel like the stock market is
basically the same way
you got these [ __ ] which would make
sense why
we haven't have not tried to embrace
solar [ __ ] power
and different alternative forms of
[ __ ] energy considering we've been
under the thumb of these blue blood
[ __ ]
oil companies and banks forever
oh i got it all figured out over here um
but that's what see and that's what
[ __ ] blows my mind
and then when something like hap
that happens and it's like well there it
is there it is
they just shut off they just [ __ ] hit
pause
on the stock market these head fudge
guys just [ __ ] did that
made a few phone calls that was it right
i didn't know you could there it is
right [ __ ] there yeah they blow right
by it
doesn't fit the narrative um
i know i got a lot of mistakes in that
i'm still reading up on it but you guys
it wasn't bad
that wasn't for bad for a guy that went
to summer school a lot more than he
didn't
right whatever the worst case scenario i
made i made you feel smarter
isn't that what you want isn't that why
you're listening to this well isn't it
um all right where the [ __ ] am i in all
of this
you know i looked up a bunch of people
man i was watching that ken burns
documentary on baseball and i just
jumped in the middle and what's great
about it is it's
it's so this each episode's so
interesting it doesn't even [ __ ]
matter where you jumped in
i jumped in in the uh the 60s and 70s
and um
just i loved the 60s with all those
overpowering pitchers
the point they had to lower the mound
because they were just so [ __ ]
dominant
the bob gibsons the sandy cofaxes all of
those guys i love
that whole era um
i love those ballparks right before they
took them down
those original ballparks the original
great ballparks
you know connie mack stadium
the polo grounds ebbets field
which i guess they took down in like
1960 but you know what i mean all of
those original yankee stadium
um where the hell the pirates played
forbes field
just all all of that type of [ __ ]
i love all of that stuff so i was
watching that thing and um
there was some stat in there that
absolutely blew my [ __ ] mind
i can't remember if it was it was bob
gibson
oh yeah bob gibson do you know in 1967
he came out against jim longberg of the
red sox ace
we had taken them seven games and he had
won two games
and longberg had won two games and as
was the red sox luck for so many years
longberg was was pitching on only two
days rest and bob gibson
had his full whatever rest and he came
out not only did he dominate the red sox
he got up to the plate and hit a [ __ ]
home run
i was like wow i didn't know that it's
[ __ ] amazing so anyway let me read a
little bit of advertising here
um and i'm looking forward to all of you
guys
giving me [ __ ] slash teaching me more
about the stock market one oh there's no
what happened you dumb freckled [ __ ]
i know i know i'm trying
all right helix everybody you know not
being
able to sleep because of today's
politics pandemics
your love life your balls are full any
other drama
you talk about in your show um
oh i guess i wasn't supposed to read
that that was in red
okay red's for red the black and white
this is for you guys all right helix
sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete you know you're
supposed to brush your teeth for two
minutes
time it takes to brush your teeth you
can complete this two minute quiz
for helix sleep that will match your
body your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way you
sleep everybody's unique everybody's
special
and helix knows that so they have
several different mattress models to
choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling down
if you sleep hot disgusting and even a
helix plus mattress for plus size
folks the old fatty's got a big mattress
for you
right what if you got a lot of
junk and you like to sleep on your
stomach do they did they scoop out some
of the mattress
see your junk and be there i mean these
guys are there what they're doing at
this mattress factory
is incredible uh it's been awesome
getting messages from so many of you who
also found the helix
mattress of your dreams so if you're
looking for a mattress
you take the quiz you order the mattress
that you match to and the mattress comes
right to your door shipped
for free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again
helix is awesome but you don't need to
take my word for it helix was awarded
the number one best overall mattress
pick of 2020
and by gq and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com
b-u-r-r take their two-minute sleep quiz
i already told you this and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you
the best sleep sleeper your life helix
sleep h-e-l-i-x
sleep s-l-e-e-p dot com slash bar
b-u-r-r
helix is now offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com they have a 10-year
warranty
and you get to try it out for a hundred
nights risk-free they even pick it up if
you don't love it gross
but you will all right who's next oh
look who it is it's all indochino
share some of your favorite wardrobe
moments for example dressing to impress
for an interview or a date or a special
occasion you want it to look as
especially sharp four well you know what
it never really rains out here
in uh los angeles and when i was in
iceland i actually bought a great
raincoat and it was raining out and i
got to put it on
you know and i walked around all these
los angelinos who don't have
raincoats because it never rains out
here and you know what i i felt really
good about myself
i felt a pep in my step and i felt you
know
like if indochino made a uh made a
cologne i was wearing it
all right make every moment an
opportunity to look your best with
indochino
perfectly fitted custom custom clothes
perfectly fitted custom clothes are more
of photo affordable than you might think
and no offers complete why can't i talk
now offers completely custom fitted
suits
coats and casual wear what is that
sweatpants
and surprisingly affordable prices
customize
everything from the fabric and the
lining to the lapel
shape and the monogram the choice is
yours and since your order is made to
your exact measurements
and peace will each piece will fit you
unless you go on an eating bench you
know and your style perfectly
the best part indochino suits start at
just 2.99
with all customizations included that's
off a purchase of 3.99 or more
at indochino.com
promo code burr book a virtual
appointment and shop online at
indochino.com i
n d o c h i
n o dot com i n d o c h
i n o com and right now you'll get 30
off
any purchase of 3.99 or more
when you enter the code burr into the
code the code
burb at checkout oh jesus look who it is
everybody it's me
it's me undies
me undies i didn't like that joke
do me undies me undies i mean to take a
medical toke
and smoke some weed to forget about my
problems and get in a car
and go down the street the cops can't
test for it cause it's weed
i don't [ __ ] really get that as a
drinker all right
me undies everybody hi friends meundies
believes that comfort is about more than
what's touching your skin
it's about feeling comfortable in your
own skin yes honey
it's time to accept you in your drawers
uh you're a total badass and what you
wear should only accentuate that
all right let's not get crazy here me
undies okay to be a badass you got to be
a badass
and to be a badass most people have to
not be a badass or else then you're just
a regular [ __ ] person all right
you're not a total badass
all right let's let's fix this copy all
right you think you're a total badass
you want to dress like you're a badass
and meundie says the [ __ ]
underwear what is what does badass
underwear look like
i'll tell you what it looks like it
looks like
it was sustainable breathable soft as
heck fabric
talking micro modal fistful of dollars
grabbing your [ __ ] junk as you walk
down the street
caressing it enough to make you feel
comfortable but not enough to make you
aroused so you can still function in
that meeting
but they also give you endless styles to
choose from it's a total
it's total comfort inside and out
different prints colored styles meundies
offers classic colors to ridiculous
prints
they have new ones that have [ __ ] stains
in them already
so if you [ __ ] yourself you can say no
that's the pattern i mean these guys
think i'm kidding i'm kidding
but they do think of everything meundies
offers classic colors to
to ridiculous prints it's all so you can
fully express yourself in your own
unique way me undies
are available in a range of sizes from
extra small
to 4xl all right
if you're a little fella or a [ __ ]
lard ass they have
they have the underwear for you never
leave your couch again with me undies
with a miandi's membership a monthly
subscription that sends new pairs
right to you do with site-wide savings
and exclusive sales you'll automatically
pay less for everything me undies has a
great offer for my listeners
for anytime uh first-time purchasers you
get 15
off and free shipping myani's also has
their problem-free philosophy
if you're not satisfied with any product
for any reason they'll refund it or
exchange it no caveats no questions
isn't that great that's what business
used to be uh to get your 15
off your first order and free shipping
go to meundies.com that's meundies.com
all right who else spaghetti oh look who
it is my bookie hey how the [ __ ] you
doing huh you've been around here
uh my bookie um can the all-time goat
get it done against the future goat
um let's see here brady and mahomes
going head to head and everyone
talking about who
and number 39 is going to win the big
game i think there's a typo there
all of a sudden you went to like uh
punctual with not punctuation what'd you
call that
you know you know the thing for the and
and then the number signed
i don't know what the [ __ ] that means
all right whether you're on the chiefs
or bucks just remember
uh where you're betting is just as
important as who you're betting on
that's why
i always tell my friends to go to my
bookie
my book he has all the props for the big
game these guys truly
let you bet on anything whether it's the
length of the national anthem
mvp or the color of the sports drink
dumped on the winning coach my bookie
has a
buffet of chiefs bucks props for you to
chew on
now how the [ __ ] are they going to
handicap what color the gatorade's going
to be
i guess what you do is you offer a bunch
of colors
and that gives them so they won't lose
their shirt
then you can still win money all right
you can even win big on nfl squares no
need to leave the comfort of your home
you can access the sports book and
casino right
from your iphone all right from your
phone sorry don't miss out on the last
game of the year
sign up at my bookie today and use the
promo code burr burr
to have your deposit matched halfway up
to a grand
that's a free cash bonus just for making
your deposit use promo code bird to
claim the offer
bet win and get paid at my bookie guess
what i'm gonna look at the spread right
now
and i'm gonna give you my [ __ ] what
i'm gonna do here
super bowl spread
kansas city minus three
that's it they're only given three
points
oh i don't like that i was hoping i i
wanted like
four or five and then i would have
buried the buccaneers
we shall see i think it's gonna come
down to coaching i really do with all
this talk about brady and [ __ ] my
homes i think it's gonna come down to
who's the but who's got the better game
plan
all right that's what it's gonna come
down to i don't think it's gonna come
down to those two guys
i think somebody's going to have to
belichick the other guy's team
and that that guy is uh was it bruce
ahrens is that his name the guy from
tampa bay
that coach needs to bill belichick
andy reed's team that's what he needs to
do
all right because if he doesn't
the [ __ ] chiefs are just gonna run
away with it that's what i think
uh but they got tom brady i'm taking tom
brady and i'm taking the points
all right i'm bill burn i support this
message all right mack weldon
one-stop shop men's essentials
some socks shirts hoodies underwears
polos and active
shorts mack weldon promises comfort
and a consistent fit you're not just
going to
look great in mack weldon their
underwear socks and shirts perform well
too
from working out going out going to work
running from the cops
mack weldon is there from everyday life
fabric and technology
mark weldon offers a wide range of
customized fabrics
that can keep up with you no matter what
your day looks like
18 hour silver air knit dry knit
warm knit [ __ ] nit they got it all
mark weldon has created a totally free
loyalty program
level one gets you free shipping for
life once you reach level 2 by spending
200 bucks
mac welding gives you 20 off every order
for the next
year that's amazing all right
your experience call to action use the
talking points above to
guide your narrative but we want to hear
it in your words well why the [ __ ] would
you write that in the end
all right let me do mac welding again in
my own words you know what
we got a new guy here uh mack weldon
guys got socks shirts hoodies underwears
polo i'm just reading that thing so i'm
just yelling it now
whatever you know what the deal is all
right you okay for 20 off your first
order visit
mack weldon m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n.com
and enter the promo code burr b-u-r-r
repeat
the 20 off your first order offer and
url
promo code twice well just write it out
all right i got to repeat the two okay
you get 20 off your first order
okay i did that and i got to do the url
promo code twice macweldon.com once
again that's mackweldon.com
m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d-o-n
here we go find a better [ __ ] read in
the business
i know you can do that go [ __ ] yourself
all right let's move on here let's move
on with the podcast get to your
uh i got one announcement here i got a
podcast with verzi
i'm just doing podcasts with my friends
now you know considering you know i
guess i don't know when this [ __ ]
pandemic is gonna end so i'm just gonna
[ __ ] i'm just gonna podcast while i'm
waiting
i have a new podcast with paul verzi
please subscribe to anything better
on your podcast application of choice
and on your youtube
for full video links will be in the
podcast description
um all right printer inc wait did i miss
the
was that something i was supposed to
read not a [ __ ] all right printer ink
yeah i learned about printer hey bill i
don't think i don't know if this works
but
have you tried printing in like navy
blue or something
dark instead of black maybe still the
computer will say it needs black in
but it will be still be legible just a
thought by the way you can change the
color by choosing
select all then click that little menu
with the black
bar you know i know you can do all of
that i just can't figure out how to do
it
and i also found out you can buy black
ink on its own so there goes that
conspiracy theory too
all right i also figured out the reason
why my tv downstairs never [ __ ] works
is because i was hitting the wrong
[ __ ] button i mean i've learned a lot
okay the problem is me all right attic
in insulation
response hi bill maybe too late here for
a tip
regarding your recent renovation project
but here goes from
architect slash contractor with 35 years
in the biz ah
[ __ ] please don't tell me you're going
to tell me i did
everything wrong blown in insulation is
really effective
the rollout fiberglass type leaves gaps
if not installed carefully well i got
good guys to do it all right you're not
going to make me question myself now
blown in
is made from recycled newspaper and
treated with the fire [ __ ]
blown in leaves no gaps and should be at
a thickness
specific to la every region in the
country has a code
or required r value related to a local
climate
um it can be installed thicker if you
want a higher r value for greater
efficiency
with either type the efficiency is
greatly reduced if all holes
gaps are not air sealed i.e wire holes
electric boxes for ceiling lights
recessed lights covers says it's
plumbing holes gaps above the intent you
get
if either type is used and installed to
the required r
value but not first
air sealed dude couldn't you just let me
be happy with my [ __ ] insulation now
i'm gonna be all freaked out
it's it's i appreciate that you wrote in
there i'm [ __ ] with you
it's as a result not meeting the r value
and not as effective
lots of videos out there another
important part is roof venting
too much to address here but that's
absolutely worth looking into as well
um plumbing hot water pipes should be
insulated
hot water will then reach each fixture
sooner
and conserves water um even
insulating coal pipes doesn't hurt
in some cases as in an attic they can
can
condensate soak the insulation drip in
stains ceilings etc oh jesus
other insulation benefits keeps the heat
out
sound deadening helicopters neighbors
don't have to hear you screaming riffing
ranting or nia screaming for the
millionth time
trying to get you to shut the [ __ ] up
hope it's not too late good luck bill
and go [ __ ] yourself yeah i was a little
late
um you know what's funny is everybody i
met said they hated the spray
and that it sucks and it's a i think
because it's they all have to try and
work around it rather than just rolling
it up it's a big pain in the ass for
them maybe that's what it was but
i appreciate you letting me know that
i've put the wrong insulation into my
head
i didn't say it was wrong it just needs
to be make sure there's no gaps
but i think they did a great job um
unfortunately i'm coming to the end here
of
things i need to do to my house and the
last thing i need to do
um technically i don't need to do it
because nothing's happening right now
but i don't want to wait until something
does happen
i.e my seward pipe out to the street
splits after 100 years of [ __ ]
film noir shit's going through it
all right update from 128
19 podcast episode re
failed vasectomy hey billy sad tits uh
writing with an update from your january
28 2019 episode regarding
failed vasectomies i am the pregnant
girlfriend
referenced oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i don't remember this but i love
hearing
finally hearing from the other side
listen to this okay my ex-boyfriend
wrote in about having a vasectomy
me accidentally getting pregnant and
asked you for advice
my ex-boyfriend idolizes you and used
the situation
situation in quotes to get your
attention he also used
the feature on your podcast to
legitimize
himself to me at the time i had no idea
that he had lied to me about his entire
background
and identity including having a
vasectomy
oh my god uh yep that lying stupid
sociopath
pathic [ __ ] lied about having a
vasectomy then got me pregnant
and then tried manipulating me into
keeping the baby
including writing to you asking what
should we do
when i'd already made it clear that i
would not be keeping the baby because
we'd only been dating for three months
at the time
holy [ __ ] this guy's a lunatic
um or you killed him and came up with
this as your alibi but this is this is
riveting to give more background
he's covered in tattoos of a city he's
never lived in
in a region he wasn't raised with and
doesn't even practice
oh my god while we were dating his dad
contracted a terminal cancer
and air quote died but i now know his
dad is alive and well
i'm barely scratching the surface here
on all his lies and deception
wow i know you joke around a lot but i'd
love to know
your serious thoughts on what type of
person behaves like this
well the type of person that i wish you
didn't describe it so well on this
podcast
um is i don't need this guy [ __ ]
getting upset with me
this guy sounds crazy manipulates people
on this massive scale by the way
i'm sorry you were also deceived by this
sad sack of [ __ ]
sending love to your family and baby
girl well i mean
i just i mean i just read these things
like they're true i mean it didn't
really affect my life i think as much as
you um
wow i don't know why i have no [ __ ]
idea that would be like but if i was a
psychologist these are the people i
would want to treat
just for the entertainment value of like
what the [ __ ] he gonna say today
you know i just would i would like
i tried to like feed him you know to see
what he come up with be like okay did
you see uh chuck yeager just passed away
and he'd just be oh you know i met chuck
you i just said
okay here we go um
let's see here pathological
liars why
why do they lie okay
some limes seem to be told in order to
make the pathological liar appear the
hero
or to gain acceptance or sympathy while
there's seemingly nothing to be gained
from other lies
some evidence from the 2007 from 2007
suggests that issues
affecting the central nervous system may
predispose someone to pathologically
lying
pathological liar how to cope with
someone's being a pathological liar
oh yeah break up with them uh
pathological lying also known as
mythomania and suladona
fantastica is the chronic behavior of
compulsive or habitual lying unlike
telling the occasional white lie
um to avoid hurting someone's feelings
or getting in trouble a pathological
liar seems to lie for no apparent reason
this can make it frustrating or hard to
know what to do
if you believe uh what wait
or hard to know what to do if you
believe you've met one
well it's it's easy you just get them
out of your life
though pathological lying has been
recognized you don't be amazing if two
pathological liars met each other in a
bar
like how long could they lie to each
other before they would both realize
oh wait this person's doing what i'm
doing or would they catch it quicker
because
you know they'd see it they could
because that's what they do you know
what i mean
i don't know well i'm sorry
you got knocked up by a pathological
liar
um but am i supposed to believe you at
this point because now i believed him i
mean i don't know
who knows all right girlfriend
questioned my sexuality
good morning [ __ ] i like that
it's a different one
good morning [ __ ] big fan of the
podcast and stand ups thank you
the michelle obama bit from paper tiger
actually
made me cry laughing that's hilarious i
was talking about doing that i did a
corp i did a private show one time at
this guy's house out in [ __ ]
malibu right on the ocean and i did that
bit
right before i did it on my special and
whoo
did not go over well um anyway so in
nashville
with my girlfriend and all her friends
four dudes seven girls four day weekend
uh i have met them all and wait wait
what what just happened
so in nashville is how that sentence
starts so in nashville with my
don't you mean so i'm in nashville with
my girlfriend and all her friends four
dudes
and seven girls for a four day weekend i
have met them all at different points
and while i thought
they were losers as my girlfriend
describes they were all real nice
just not really my type of people or
vibe
wait a minute your girlfriend described
her friends as losers
i'm confused there's four dudes and
seven girls four day weekend i've met
them all at different points and while i
thought they were losers
as my girlfriend describes they were all
real nice just not really my
okay so you thought they were losers she
said no they're nice just not your type
of people
parentheses dubstep at 10 in the morning
making jokes about drinking again entire
weekend i'm watching all these dude
wrestle around and grab each other's
dick
dicks fair to say for context i wrestled
in high school
and when i asked what the [ __ ] are y'all
doing
i was told it was just wrestling i
should
i should get it
uh okay all right bro i never put my
hand on my buddy's [ __ ]
five times while we were wrestling in
front of a party
for the record me and my friends don't
do that at
all let alone in public i consider
myself
a man's man and don't like to be touched
by girls who aren't my girlfriend let
alone other dudes
we are at a bar tempers are up cause
i didn't want to be there anyway the one
guy who sent it
all over the edge just does there's no
punctuation in this everybody
just doesn't walk right
man the dude sashays when he walks
oh i see i see what's going on here
you know walks with his hips and [ __ ]
and as my girl puts it
hates his girlfriend i'm thinking it's
because she's not his type
as in female okay and this douchebag
tries to sit on my lap
and i laughed it off and was like nah
bro not me
then he puts his hand on my inner thigh
and asked me what's wrong
looking into my eyes like he's ready to
[ __ ] me in front of
god and everyone uh
yeah this is not this is none of this is
cool this guy should not be doing any of
this [ __ ]
i've been told i have a bill bird temper
oh jesus and i lost it
and when she asked me what's wrong he's
just trying to be nice
i said no he's trying to [ __ ] me because
this dude is gay and she says
why do you think he's gay are you that
uncomfortable with your sexuality of
course
of course i knew it was gonna get thrown
back at you
you know if if that was reversed it was
some guy putting his hand on her inner
thigh
and she goes and she flipped out you
would back her
you know it's your body don't touch me
right
that seems to only work for women anyway
so naturally i left the bar
and broke up with her as soon as we got
home nice move
nice move that was a good move because
this this is like the whole
you just got to take the sickle out he
goes kind of blew up and decided to not
it
to not end it like that but now i am
sitting here thinking hey i'm 21
why still stay with this girl
who is cool and could be the mother of
my children blonde nursing major without
daddy issues i mean come on i know a
unicorn when i see one no you don't
you're 21.
so am i just wondering if so i am
just wondering if you would stay with
her after that
thanks man for all the content you're
the man go [ __ ] yourself well listen
i would appreciate capital letters and
punctuations
if you're gonna write something that
long i mean dude i don't know how you
feel about this chick
i mean that sounds like pretty [ __ ]
crazy
what happened in the bar but i think a
lot of guys myself included
have been in that situation you know
that guy who's pretending to be straight
but isn't straight and then he has a few
and then what he really is starts coming
out and then when you're kind of going
like hey i don't i don't go that way
then all of a sudden it becomes your
problem which is weird
so um i know you did the right thing get
the [ __ ] off me
i don't like being touched like that by
another guy [ __ ] off leave me alone
you're well within your right to do that
that doesn't make you homophobic or
anything like that
that's just makes you you have nice
solid [ __ ] boundaries
no one should be touching anybody if
they don't want to be [ __ ] touched
right
and then second of all you got the [ __ ]
out of there which is great because you
got a temper like me
fantastic so you got the [ __ ] out of
there and then in the end you said [ __ ]
this i'm breaking up with you
now did you break up with her because
she wasn't supporting you or because you
were so freaked out by what that guy did
that's what i would figure out but like
uh
i kind of like the whole clean slate
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm out of here
um because i gotta be honest with you
like that's not
cool or her to not have you back in that
situation
so i would say what i would do if i was
you
i'd think about it and after a few days
you know if you're not just afraid to be
single if it's not those feelings if
you're truly missing her then i'd sit
down with it i try to work it out i talk
to her and just tell her like why that
bothered you
you know um all right there's that
okay guys you know how bad i read out
loud so please
if you could just help me out with
capital letters punctuation
you know instead of just voice texting
the whole [ __ ] thing and then hitting
send
all right uh my best friend came on to
me
while my girlfriend is in the hospital
my best friend came on to me while my
girlfriend is in the hospital
all right dear billy red beard now what
i love about this is i don't know
which way this is gonna go okay is this
a lesbian
and her girlfriend's in the hospital and
this is a female chick coming onto her
is this a dude um all right me and my
friend
have been is this a guy with a
girlfriend
and then his best friend dude came on to
dude best friend
male best friend how the [ __ ] do you say
it lost in pronouns
okay me and my friend have been friends
for two years
she helped me get comfortable in the
state i now live in after i moved from
my hometown
and nothing like this has ever happened
before most recently she helped me get
through
my girlfriend of a little under a year
being in the hospital for the past four
months
here's the problem last week we were
hanging out in our backyard
we were tossing back a few beers and
generally just shooting the [ __ ]
we were six feet apart so there's no
need to report me to the cdc
we both drank a little too much that
night and at one point she was leaning
over me
trying to kiss me i literally had to
hold up my hand to stop our lips from
making content
contact i was pretty drunk and was so
caught off guard that all i could think
to say was
no thank you she went back to her seat
and we kept talking but the energy had
changed
the next morning she texted me saying
drank more than she should have
and she said she didn't remember much of
our conversation but i think she was
lying yeah she was embarrassed
she has to hang out once since the
incident but i turned it down well
that's good you got good boundaries
now here's my question is there any way
i can stay friends with this girl
without
being a terrible boyfriend
i know i probably have to distance
myself from her for a while
it's just that she means a lot to me as
a friend
is there some hope of salvaging the
friendship or is it beyond repair
the lovely nia has any advice maybe she
could provide a woman's perspective
thank you go [ __ ] yourself um
unfortunately she's not here
um my gut is telling me
that the reason why she was so friendly
to you and has been helping you for so
[ __ ] long since you came there
is because she's liked you the whole
time
and uh
maybe she was hoping that you'd like her
like that and you don't or whatever but
she still likes you that way and she got
a little drunk and then
tried to kiss you i don't know but uh i
don't know i don't know what her deal is
but i
i can tell you this like uh
as far as boyfriend girlfriend yeah you
can't hang out with her
just what if your girlfriend had the
same thing happen with the guy
and he tried to kiss her but she still
wanted to hang out and be friends
you wouldn't you wouldn't be comfortable
with that and that would not be cool
right so
it's the same thing with her she would
not be cool you don't need to bring it
up
i just would you know
you know some secret should just keep
okay you can handle this thing in-house
you don't need to [ __ ] cause all this
goddamn i'm in the [ __ ] hospital
and you're trying to kiss my boyfriend
sorry you don't need that [ __ ]
just you know
i don't i don't want to tell you i never
i didn't have female friends when i was
your age
like that because that [ __ ] would happen
so i don't know how to handle that one
a lot of stuff above my pay grade all
right i apologize to everybody who
actually pays attention to the news and
is into finance
that actually understands what shorting
a stock is i think i did an okay job
trying to explain it well you know bill
sometimes
okay isn't is it not it's just not good
enough
you know it's just not good enough um
all right anyways that's the podcast for
this week the bruins got the capitals
tonight who the celtics got next
this is so [ __ ] incredible to be home
and be able to watch this [ __ ] like i
have like a nine to five
you know it's weird is what it is
we have the golden state warriors oh
okay all right
and we got the kings then we got the
clippers
we got to be on the road then we got the
suns yeah we got to be on the road here
what are the odds all of them would come
to our place then we got the jazz
and then we're home for the raptors whoa
look at that one two three four
five game road trip the warriors the
kings the clippers the suns and the jazz
all right how do you get tickets to
these games by the way
and there's only like 18 people in the
crowd
celtics are playing the clippers friday
february 5th man i wonder if i can get
two tickets to that how do you do that
take my lovely wife out i am you know
what i might do that
god jesus is there like [ __ ] like one
scalper down there with the mask on
he has all the tickets jesus christ
um anyway all right let's plow it how
few people are going to be at a wnba
game i mean it already looked like a
[ __ ] pandemic the entire time that i
will still never understand why women
are not going to those games packing it
to the [ __ ] rafters
you know oh that's right they don't get
along with each other
okay everybody that is
[ __ ] with you that is the podcast for
monday go [ __ ] yourselves and i'll check
in on you
on thursday go bruins go celtics go [ __ ]
yourself
you